we think of animated shows as harmless
kids fair but that isn't always the case
each of these cartoon episodes were so
raunchy so stupid or so downright
confusing that they would denied an
audience entirely from its 1994 debut at
gargoyles gained a devoted fanbase for
its complex plots fluid animation and
serious storytelling as an
action-adventure series chronicling the
lives of gargoyles who come to life at
nights to protect the places and people
they love the series explored themes
including frustrated love urban crime
and corporate greed this willingness to
go to intense places made gargoyles and
enduring hits that lives on in cosplay
and tie-in comics to this day but in the
minds of network executives it also
crossed the line the season 1 episode
deadly forces are compassionate albeit
stern story about gun safety in which
fun-loving gargoyle Broadway
accidentally shoots human detective
ELISA with her own gun she is badly
wounded and barely survives emergency
surgery and Broadway goes on a frantic
guilt ridden crusade against guns
ultimately a very important lesson is
learned about the safe handling of
firearms but not before several seconds
of a laser with a bullet and a belly
filled the screen
[Music]
deadly force was pulled from rotation
for a while and subsequent airings on
spin off channels Toon Disney and Disney
XD
we cut the scene to the only ELISA
sangwich face is visible regardless the
gargoyles team remains proud of the
message they sent about gun violence in
this episode and stand bias is a
thoughtful examination of firearms and
their mishandling Dexter's Lab was one
of the biggest successes of 1990s
animation and a reverence end up of
everything from mid-century space-age
ambition the marble action heroes at the
heart of it was Dexter megalomaniacal
child genius with a secret lab behind
his bedroom bookcase and DeeDee his
goofy to to clad sister their clashes to
find many episodes of the show and
typically went to bizarre extremes as
when Dexter sought to grow a beard to
display his manliness after Dee Dee's
teasing or indeedy inspired a crush in
Dexter's arch-nemesis Mandark that
sibling rivalry reached new heights in
Dexter's rood removal innocent from us
episode dexter develops a rude removal
system to remove dee dee's more
irritating qualities this backfires and
Dexter ends up creating two versions of
himself and his sister a polite vaguely
British pair and a pair whose every
other word is censored by profanity
bleeps the spiders completion of
Dexter's Rood removal never aired
series creator again the Tartakovsky
mentioned it from time to time growing
its legend until finally it surfaced on
late-night programming block Adult
Swim's websites despite the fact that no
curse word is ever actually uttered
uncensored the mere fact of their
existence was too much for delicate ears
Tiny Toon Adventures was known for its
prior attitude toward cartoon
conventions ABS Buster and the rest of
the acme looniversity gang regularly
poked fun of the expectations and tropes
of the media from subverting slapstick
gags involving mullets and banana peels
for the contrasting iconic jokesters
like Bugs Bunny and Daffy Duck with
genteel mortarboards and academic robes
as a University's professors from the
cartoon setting in a town called Acme
acres two characters names like Mary
melody riffing off Warner Brothers
legendary Merrie Melodies cartoons the
whole cartoon rests on a foundation of
metatextual ribbing but that went a
little off the rails for the infamously
bands one beer plucky duck Hampton J pig
and Buster bunny go on a whirlwind
bender when they drink beer for the
first time quickly
from wide-eyed kids to stubble chind and
lowlifes
despite the fact that Buster opens he
escapades buyout rise saying in this
episode we're showing the evils of
alcohol and ending it by asking if they
can do a funny episode tomorrow now that
they've lectured the kids one beer was
banned until 2013 when it was finally
included in a DVD release let that be a
lesson to animators across the globe
don't try to teach valuable lessons cow
and chicken never pretended to be
anything but crass its titular siblings
excitable second grader cow and
hot-tempered fifth grader chicken
regularly got into trouble that made it
clear that they were there to make kids
laugh not provide moral guardianship
take for example their enemy red guy it
might have actually been the devil but
was most notable for not wearing pants
among his many aliases were officer
pants coughs kee mrs. bad area major
wedgie and no pants de Leon no joke was
too crude for this cartoon to indulge
there was however a limit the censors
did not want crust and cow and chicken
found it with Buffalo gals seven solid
minutes of lesbian jokes and
surprisingly if faced resistance from
network executives although it lives on
through the magic of the Internet
Dudley do-right Stokey the bear was
intended in the spirits of fun panaderia
is roundly if kindly parodied in the
episode is the home of trees Lumberjacks
a firewood industry and well not much
else snidely whiplash is doing his
diabolical deeds to better barbecue his
hotdogs Stokey was meant to be very much
a parody of smokey if only you can
prevent forest fires fame by hitting the
thighs by snidely into setting fires all
in good fun right wrong the u.s. Forest
Service wasn't to be pleased with a
spoof of their beloved mascots in no
small part because smokey was created
with a very particular purpose in mind
one the episode was deliberately
muddling understandable perhaps
especially given that the episodes final
gag implies stoke he was responsible for
the Great Chicago Fire of 1871 the
episode was yanked Stokie was snuffed
and it never saw our time again Batman
The Brave and the bold was a
self-conscious tribute and recreation of
Silver Age DC Comics brights funny and a
bascially nonsensical from the retro
aesthetic to capers of titles like
invasion of the Secret Santas Raven the
bold was all about having a good and
goofy time mostly this resulted in
kid-friendly hygiene for the laser guns
and magical truth serum
riot II but in the mask of matches
Malone praising the bold got downright
naughty when they're caught sneaking
into a nightclub interest Catwoman and
Black Canary think fast and perform
birds-of-prey
a throwback toe-tapper about the men of
the DC Universe that stuffs an innuendo
into every other line this ranges from
Catwoman purring what a weapon what a
bang about Batman the implication that
Green Arrow doesn't always shoot
straight and a complaint about the flash
being just too fast but what got the
episode booted off the season 2 DVD
collection was a suggestive finger
waggle Huntress deploys when discussing
Aquaman with a bit of reanimation to
remove the tell-tale finger it was
included as a bonus episode on the
season 3 DVD and this everyone now knows
all about the male members of the
Justice League and their prowess on and
off the battlefield cast your mind back
to 1987 and recall the Garbage Pail Kids
Trading Card their success rested
entirely upon the fact that they were
utterly disgusting there's lots of facts
of childhood grotesquerie a perfect
parody of the apple-cheeked goodness of
the Cabbage Patch Kids
was such characters as atom bomb Suzie
Suzie and snow witch Sandra they were
pulling no punches when it came to
grossing kids out and cracking them up
but the 1987 garbage pail kids cartoon
went too far for the us viewing audience
starring split Kids Bob Dwayne Elliott
mess terrycloth and patty [ __ ] the
eponymous kids use their disgusting
powers to save the day groups including
action for children's television and
Christian leaders for Responsible
television protested however and the
show was yanked from the airwaves mere
days before release though it did go on
to air in other countries and never saw
the light of US viewership the Garbage
Pail Kids were to be frank dumped the
english-language dub of anime mega hit
Sailor Moon Curtain censored so many
things on the original Japanese version
it merits a video of its own many of
these changes have become infamous
Sailor Uranus and Sailor Neptune
originally lovers were changed to
cousins and multiple instances of
implied nudity was scrapped before many
of these now infamous choices were made
however was day of destiny the finale to
season 1 originally a two-parter day of
destiny sees Sailor Moon and company's
summer Evil Queen barrels Arctic
fortress her henchmen attack and the
battle quickly goes south
sailors Mercury Mars Jupiter and Venus
or die
the ice and Sailor Moon is forced to
fight the supercharged Beryl on her own
given that the original Japanese title
of the first episode is death the Sailor
Guardians the tragic final battle
it is perhaps unsurprising that it was
Kurt and the finale reduced to one
cobbled together episode for the US
market while it wasn't outright banned
the original version was just too much
for kids 1990s playgrounds the world
over found themselves per set by a new
fad it was called Pokemon and is still
us yet to release its grip on young
minds kids just can't get enough of pika
- squirtle and the gang but a rumor
haunted the franchise early on beat a
ting as it passed from kid to kid there
was an episode they whispered that was
burned the internet was in its infancy
and no one had ever seen the fabled
episode and so the tales grew and checks
even today you might hear a child
whisper about a killer episode of
Pokemon and no one has ever seen unlike
other kids bred legends this one really
did turn out to be true electric soldier
porygon is the episode in question and
it was indeed banned from the airwaves
for reasons of Public Health hundreds of
Japanese children were rushed to the
hospital after it aired in 1997
suffering from seizures convulsions and
vomiting it turned out that a brief
moment of bright strobing animation into
stillness and set off a generations
favorite bit of gossip twenty years
later it still fascinates us though
luckily those prone to seizures know to
keep well away the Powerpuff Girls was
never a show content to be normal the
very premise itself man combines sugar
spice everything nice and the mysterious
black ooze creates triplets is bizarre
and episodes hinged on everything from
elaborate Beatles parodies to the
sinister effects of glue consumption but
in season five see me feel me know me
this was taken to new heights in a no
Marge - rock operas like Tommy the
episode is a song through musical in
which the girls meet a magical gnome who
promises to vanquish all evil in
exchange for their powers and he makes
Townsville into a cult eventually the
day is saved
Townsville is restored and the moments
to feeted so why did Cartoon Network
keep the episode off US Airways
questions swirled for years until show
creator craig mccracken finally provided
some answers via his tumblr they banned
it because they claimed that the metal
beams in the destroyed buildings looks
too much like crosses and one of the
hippies looked like Jesus a staff was
surprised and the fans were deprived but
it all worked out in the end the episode
is now available to anyone who wants to
watch it on Hulu
iTunes or on the original series DVDs
anime exploded into popularity in the
late 1990s and tsunami a cartoon network
programming block aimed at the action
hungry after-school crowd was a huge
part of why from Sailor Moon to Dragon
Ball Z to Nami yet the coolest edgiest
often weirdest cartoons Western kids had
ever seen and it kept them glued to
their TVs new episodes appear daily
movie length specials were hyped for
weeks prior to airing and occasionally
Toonami even pushed the boundaries of
what was considered acceptable action
was tougher faster and more intense on
Toonami and jokes for a bit more edgy
outlaw star a spacefaring action series
often pushed that line but one whole
episode was deemed unacceptable
impossible to edit into suitability and
and ceremoniously dumped it's no
surprise as to why hot springs planet 10
racis hero teen star Windus enter a
world of beautiful saunas filled with
even more beautiful and always enclosed
ladies in the end the kiddy viewers just
had to deal with the lack of continuity
until many years later it's aired in the
late-night we imagine Toonami intended
for just those kids had loved it the
first time around check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos but your favorite
cartoons are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the bowel so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]